Bien le bonjour les amis ! Comment allez-vous ?
Petit kawa (café) qui met bien.
Toi même tu connais, le matin.
Au moment où vous regardez cette vidéo, comme vous le savez, je suis dans l'avion direction la Corée, mais là, au moment où je la fais, je suis une semaine avant.
P*tain, c'est la première fois de ma vie que j'prends de l'avance sur mes devoirs !
C'est BON !
J'ai eu une idée !
On va tenter, on est dans la propale (proposition), on tente quelque chose.
J'me suis dit "quoi de mieux avant de visiter un pays que de regarder son top des chaînes YouTube !"
Je suis donc allé sur SocialBlade.com et voici le classement des chaînes YouTube coréennes,
parce que ouais, en Corée, ils sont aussi à fond sur YouTube !
Au Japon, par exemple, ils sont un peu moins sur YouTube, ils ont un site qui s'appelle Nico Nico et, genre sur les lives, y a des centaines de milliers de personnes,
quand t'écris un commentaire, ça s'affiche en direct sur l'écran mais t'as pas besoin de faire un don, hein !
Nan ! Nan ! Nan !
Eux, c'est pas des escrocs, nan !
(sarcasme)
AAAAAAAAAHHHHH !
*cri de fierté*
Donc la première chaîne c'est BIGBANG
J'connais un peu tout ce qui est coréen (?) parce que j'ai quelqu'un autour de moi qui adore ça.
Et je sais donc que BIGBANG est un groupe de K-pop.
Donc ça c'est la première chaîne, ça c'est un petit peu finalement comme du David Guetta,
des chaînes Vevo, etc.
C'est... ça compte pas.
C'est pas des YouTubers !
"Il y a une semaine" : 20 millions de vues.
*silence de réflexion*
Ça va, ça marche bien la K-pop !
*pouffe de rire*
Bon, regardons un petit extrait !
♫♪ BIGBANG - FXXK IT ♫♪
Ok, ok, ok...
Bon voilà, c'était la K-pop !
Mais je suppose que le top 10 des premières chaînes, en fait, ça va être que des chaînes de groupes de K-pop ! *rires*
C'est tellement le truc qui CARTONNE en Corée et dans le monde !
Alors, deuxième chaîne,
c'est de la p*tain de K-pop.
Le troisième, SMTOWN...
*silence*
C'est d'la K-pop.
*rires*
Bon, on va tomber sur des gens normaux, comme nous, un jour, c'est promis !
Bon allez, on va faire un p'tit peu de culture.
En gros SMTOWN c'est une agence qui forme heu... des coréens pour qu'ils intègrent, plus tard, un groupe de K-pop et qu'ils deviennent des stars,
si le groupe marche ou pas.
Et la SMTOWN, c'est une agence qui possède notamment le plus grand groupe de K-pop de Corée qui s'appelle EXO.
♫♪ EXO - LOTTO ♫♪
On va s'bouffer que ça d'la K-pop dans cette vidéo ?!x
Est-ce qu'y a des YouTubers, hein ?!
Des puceaux comme Squeezie qui font des
vidéos là-bas !
Alors, CIENMMUSIC Official.
Nan, nan, s'il vous plaît...
KBS World TV, d'accord, donc c'est une chaîne YouTube qui appartient à une télé.
Ils font des lives ?! What the fuck, mec ?!
Leur télé, elle est reliée aussi à un flux en live sur YouTube.
*silence puis surprise*
Mais nan mec !
Mais ils sont dans le futur ! C'est un truc de ouf !
C'est génial mec !
Donc c'était pas d'la K-pop, hein ! On note.
Ok, ensuite, c'est quoi ça ?
D'la K-pop. Ne m'prenez pas pour un c*n.
♫♪ TWICE - TT ♫♪
C'est pas d'la K-pop ça ?
Nan, c'est pas un tuto beauté ça !
♫♪ TWICE - TT ♫♪
C'est vraiment pas un tuto beauté.
Oh mon gars ! Alors attends !
Donc les 6 premières chaînes, c'est d'la K-pop sauf une où c'est une chaîne de télévision et la 7ème, c'est ça.
*silence*
Oh p*tain...
Un million d'abonnés.
Et c'est des dessins animés, c'est ça ?
Attends, celui-là, il a buzzé auprès des... 4-8 ans.
Y a eu un gros buzz, on en parlait à la crèche, heu...
♫♪ PINKFONG - THE RED NOSED REINDEER RUDOLF ♫♪
C'est en ANGLAIS ?!
Mais attends, mais mec !
En fait, c'est un truc qui s'adresse totalement à un public anglophone, mais sauf que les mecs qui ont créé cette chaîne c'est des Coréens, c'est tout !
Pororo, 8ème chaîne de Corée.
70 millions de vues par mois.
*bruits de brosse à dents*
Ça, c'est des YouTubers !
*suite de la vidéo*
*rires*
Ok, c'est un mec qui se filme en POV, comme ça...
Qu'est-ce que c'est qu'ça ? Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
Ok, là, ça brosse les dents à... un animal. C'est une sorte de jeu de société, je suppose.
C'est une vidéo sponso' ouais ! Ça fait ça que pour la thune en Corée aussi !
1MILLION Dance Studio, 9ème chaîne de Corée.
Ça, c'est un studio de danse, c'est les plus talentueux de Corée, il me semble, et ils font des... des chorégraphies sur des chansons, bah, de K-pop ou autre.
Il paraît qu'ils dansent presque aussi bien que moi.
♫♪ FIFTH HARMONY - WORTH IT ♫♪
Ouais, ouais... Déjà, tu redescends.
AAAAAAAAHHHHHHHH !
*cri de douleur*
*bruit de chute*
AH ! J'ai eu... j'ai eu de l'électricité dans la jambe, mec !
Ça veut dire quoi quand on a de l'électricité dans la jambe ?
Julien Ménielle (Dans Ton Corps), s'il te plaît, j'suis abonné à ta chaîne YouTube, tu l'as jamais dit ça en vidéo.
Un docteur ? Quelqu'un ?
Bon, dites-le moi dans les commentaires.
Et mettez un pouce bleu !
*pouffe de rire*
Ah nan ! Moi, je truque pas les stats de mes vidéos !
Nan, mais attends, ils sont carrément trop chauds quoi !
Ah ! Regardez ! Ils ont fait du Rihanna. Ils ont fait du Rihanna.
♫♪ RIHANNA - WORK ♫♪
*bruit de pause*
C'est bon. C'est bon. Je, heu... ok.
Vous avez gagné, vous avez gagné, vous avez gagné.
J'mets quoi ? J'mets quoi ? J'mets le pouce bleu ? Le pouce bleu ! OK, j'mets l'pouce bleu !
Et là, j'vais m'faire traiter de PERVERS sur Twitter pendant une semaine, jusqu'au moment où vous voyez cette vidéo !
CarrieAndToys, c'est la 10ème.
Les amis,
*silence*
j'ai eu l'idée de faire cette vidéo en découvrant la chaîne de CarrieAndToys.
C'est Studio Bubble Tea, mais sans les enfants et juste avec le père. *rires*
Voilà, c'est une coréenne qui fait pareil, des histoires avec des figurines, sauf que c'est pas en POV, comme l'autre, c'est filmé de face quoi, donc on la voit.
Vu que les cultures divergent vachement, heu... un truc pour nous va sembler bizarre, chelou, alors que pour eux, c'est la norme quoi !
Ah ! Une culotte (?) géante. C'est parfait ça.
*son de la vidéo*
*éclats de rire*
Ah j'suis une p*te !
J'avance dans la vidéo, comme ça on voit l'truc carrément hors contexte donc on s'moque.
Nan mais, on est des c*nnards ! On est des...
Vous aussi ! Et ouais !
*l'animatrice parle*
*éclate de rire*
L'entrée de la poupée !
*son de la vidéo en fond*
*suite de la vidéo*
*rires*
C'est trop marrant !
400 000 vues.
Regardez, ça fait vraiment beaucoup de vues parce que les enfants, ils surkiffent en fait !
Regardez ! Y a 10 000 "j'aime" et tout !
Mais, normalement, ce que j'comprends pas c'est que normalement, les enfants, ils sont... ils regardent mais ils commentent pas, ils mettent pas de "j'aime",
ni rien sur YouTube
Regardez, les vidéos de dessins animés qui traînent sur YouTube, y a très très peu de communauté en fait, vu que c'est des enfants, juste ils regardent.
Et là non !
Voilà, les adultes approuvent quoi !
Ou alors, les enfants de 6 ans, ils sont déjà là, à écrire tranquillement en coréen, à liker...
*l'animatrice parle*
*rires*
What the fuck ?
J'aime trop !
Le mec, il peut pas parler, il est en train de mourir sous son truc.
Il fait des gestes, on sent qu'il s'énerve.
*son étouffé*
Le mec déguisé: LÀ ! L'OBJET TU LE PRENDS !
LÀ ! VAS-Y !
*l'animatrice explique son expérience*
Qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire avec du Nutella ?
Elle a mélangé de la glue avec du Nutella, un truc comme ça ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
*son de la vidéo*
Qu'est-ce qu'il s'passe là ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'notre vie ?
*l'animatrice parle*
Arrête ! Arrête ! Arrête ! ARRÊTE !
*plusieurs bruits de frappe*
*silence*
TAA-DAAAAAAAA !
*cri de joie de l'animatrice*
*silence*
*pouffe de rire*
Laisse cette pauvre pâte !
*renifle*
Ok, suivant !
Mnet K-POP.
*tape sur le bureau*
Oh ?
Bidule TV...
AAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHH !
*cri de joie*
UN YOUTUBER GAMER !
Original ! Sur Minecraft !
P*tain ! Enfin quoi ! Enfin !
Donc, le premier YouTuber Gaming, il a 1 300 000 abonnés là-bas.
C'est bizarre, parce que pourtant la Corée, c'est le pays, heu... du jeu vidéo !
Enfin, j'veux dire, c'est là-bas où y a le plus de pro-gamers, où les meilleurs joueurs d'eSport c'est carrément des rockstars de ouf !
Y a toutes les filles qui rôdent autour comme, heu...
Comme Carrie, par exemple !
Carrie: Annyeong ! (salut)
À mon avis, ils sont beaucoup plus eSport que, heu... le mec qui fait l'c*n devant des jeux vidéos.
Genre, moi, là-bas, j'serais carrément au chômage.
Donc, il fait que du Minecraft.
JTBC Entertainment: c'est des extraits de télé.
P*tain, y a très peu de YouTubers en fait, hein,
dans le top.
Mais en vrai, nous c'est pareil, y a beaucoup de chaînes Vevo d'artistes, etc.
*son de la vidéo*
What ?
Pinkfongko ? Mais on l'a pas vu au tout début ?
Pinkfong Kids Songs & Stories,
Pinkfong.
Aaaaahhh... *compréhension* C'est la même chaîne que tout à l'heure, sauf que là, les titres et les vidéos sont en coréen.
Et ça marche mieux en mode worldwide en anglais, que en Corée en coréen.
Oooh... *stupéfaction* Un gamer ?
Encore une chaîne MINECRAFT ?!
*surpris*
Mais c'est INCROYABLE !
Niveau entertainment, genre pas compétition, y a que Minecraft quoi, qui marche.
C'est ouf hein ! C'est marrant ! C'est ce que j'vous disais, ça change vachement selon les pays, c'est ouf.
Nan, celui là, il fait beaucoup de Minecraft, mais, il a fait d'autres jeux.
Toutes les 20 vidéos, il se dit "Vas-y, j'vais quand même pas faire que du Minecraft".
En fait, y a très peu de YouTubers les amis.
J'suis hyper déçu.
ibighit, ça j'connais !
Vous savez c'que c'est ?
*silence*
Faites un p'tit effort.
♫♪ BTS - BLOOD SWEAT & TEARS ♫♪
*chante en hurlant*
MANHI, MANHI, MANHIIIIIIIIII !   ( Cela veut dire "beaucoup" en coréen )
De la K-pop !
Avec un budget de clip qui s'élève à, heu...
100 millions d'euros !
Oh, c'est abusé les moyens qu'ils mettent, on voit que c'est... que ça cartonne quoi ! Regardez.
Et ces dents blanches, j'veux dire le traitement, il a dû coûter cher !
Donc en fait, écoutez, j'pense qu'on a fait le tour. Y a essentiellement des chaînes de télé et des chaînes de K-pop, et des chaînes pour enfants !
Bon bah voilà, bah écoutez, c'est la fin de cette vidéo ! Voilà !
On... on s'est instruit finalement, on en a appris un peu plus sur ce pays dans lequel je suis en train d'aller à l'heure où vous voyez cette p*tain de vidéo !
Comme promis, j'vous ferai un petit vlog là-bas, hein !
En plus, j'veux dire, là-bas, j'aurai accès à des trucs de fou quoi ! Ils ont beaucoup de respect pour les mecs qui font des conneries devant des jeux vidéos, hein...
*silence ironique*
Enfin, Minecraft uniquement.
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu !
On s'retrouve très vite dans une prochaine.
Portez-vous bien !
Profitez bien de vos petites vacances, de vos petits cadeaux, tout ça... J'vous dis à très vite !
Ciao tout l'monde...
*silence*
VITTEL ! (oh non Lucaaas... pas un placement de produit si voyant quand meme xs)
TUDUDUDU TUTUTUTUTUTU, TUDUDUDU TUTUTUTUTUTU TUTU